subaru of las vegas who is sponsoring
this next segment is always giving back
to las vegas but this time of year is
extra special
i love this time of year because it
brings out the giving side of people and
here at subaru of las vegas we're here
with burton hughes the general manager
you guys give back to the community all
year long i can only imagine what you
guys are doing for the month of december
we have a lot going on
you know it starts of course you know
subaru loves pets and it starts with a
donation drive that we got going on for
a path for paws a donation drive for
blankets and things to to just uh really
care for our shelter animals
until they get their forever homes where
we're collecting those blankets from the
first of december all the way to the
31st so jackson zoe my two pups heard
about this and they sent this down they
got this is from this is from jax
awesome and then as zoe sent this one
down as well thank you so much i love
you so much you love pets and they love
you they wanted to come help out that is
awesome thank you so much i know that's
the tip of the iceberg what else do you
guys have going on so opportunity
village from the first to the 31st we
are going to be down there the subaru of
las vegas team at the cookie factory
every friday saturday and sunday
throughout december as we volunteer and
help raise funds for the village
vernon you guys are santa's little
helpers here in las vegas
we love to give that's for sure you
truly do and you guys do work with
make-a-wish do you not we do and you
know we love to sponsor wishes and we've
got a really special wish for a young
man uh and and we're just excited we
can't wait for him to see
what we have in store you know we've
done something special with his car
burton a 1981 el camino how is this tied
into subaru and how is this tied into
make-a-wish
well the young man that owned this car
his wish
was to have a complete makeover of his
el camino
it started out gold and you know he
wanted a candy apple red and of course
the wheels the tires the interior a new
sound system and you know what he's
going to be blown away i'm sure i
absolutely let's pause for a car cutaway
burton and his crew went to town on this
el camino rebuild giving it a gorgeous
candy apple red paint job racing seats a
stunning skull theme dash and an updated
bed liner okay from a stunning rebuild
of an 81 el camino to a subaru outback
wilderness beautiful cars on the lot a
box full of toys the giving is non-stop
what is this burton we are doing a toy
drive november 18th to december the 16th
finley super las vegas is collecting new
toys for the children spending the
holidays at sunrise children's hospital
burton your giving is nonstop and that's
why we love you in subaru of las vegas
thank you so much for your time today
thank you
make a wish southern nevada hereby
announces that your wish
to have a car makeover
is coming true we have an update the
make-a-wish car rebuild was a huge
success
[Applause]
thank you to subaru of las vegas for
sponsoring this segment for more
information you can call 702-495-2100
subaru of las vegas dot com you can go
there and enter a special offer for uh
nine percent point nine percent
financing for well-qualified buyers for
up to 48 months on select 2021 models